You probably are not going to be shocked by
what I, uh, I'm going to tell you today, or
at least not surprised, but this is a major,
major scandal and it is not getting the attention
that it deserves.
A top climate scientist has quit the USDA
and claims that the Trump administration is
burying climate research data. Again, not
surprising, but a major scandal which may
not even rank given everything that's going
on right now. His name is Lewis Ziska. He's
a leading climate change scientists. He has
a study published in science advances. It's
a journal which says that more carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere causes rice to lose nutrients.
Okay. Understand the implications. Climate
change literally makes food less nutritious.
You would think that the u s d a being agriculture
would immediately be activating around this
because 600 million people on the planet depend
on rice to get enough calories. Ziska has
now gone public that the Trump administration
questioned his findings and tried to minimize
that media coverage of this study. This is
not a unique claim from Ziska. Politico did
an investigation and they found that a whole
bunch of government employees have actually
lost their jobs over climate change, disagreements
with the Trump administration and that the
USDA is regularly doing this.
They're regularly burying research that is
not favorable to Donald Trump's view of climate
change, which by the way, as a topic Trump
knows nothing about but has no shortage of
opinions on the right loves to talk about
who isn't getting to be heard. They talk about
the suppression of speech. They blame us on
the left for limiting speech and suppressing
speech. They totally misunderstand what the
first amendment is and what free speech and
censorship even mean. And here we have scientists
doing science being silenced for political
reasons. Even the Trump administration, uh,
is in a position here where they are not just
suppressing speech, they're doing even more
to hurt climate research. 550 federal workers
at the USDA were told, hey, you know what?
We're going to move the office from Washington
d C to Kansas City, a place that a lot of
people who live in Washington DC don't want
to go with peace and love and all due respect
to Kansas City, uprooting countless families.
And of course a lot of the people who have
worked for the USDA for a long time are quitting.
And who do you think they're going to be replaced
by? People that the new USTA under Trump wants
to hire. There've been lots of horrible things
happening long before Trump obviously, but
we're now seeing this sort of sinister amalgamation
of the worst instincts combined with the worst
people combined with the worst ideas combined
with a complete lack of morality and extreme
greed. And this is where they're going with
it. They aren't just trying to suppress science
and real research on the climate. They are
doing it, they are succeeding at doing it.
And it's not as salacious or headline grabbing
as a lot of the other stuff that too many
people uh, are, are spending their time on.
So a lot of people don't even realize that
this is happening and the effect is um, uh,
irreversible in many ways and sickening.
And so I'm doing my part to try to let you
know that this is going on. I understand that
the more salacious headlines will continue
to get more attention. Corporate media is
unlikely to talk about this, but for the side
that claims they are the victims of the suppression
of speech and facts, they are doing a hell
of a lot of that suppression themselves. Make
sure that you are following the David Pakman
show on twitch at twitch.tv/david Pacman.
I hope you'll join me Wednesday evening at
6:30 PM eastern for a live twitch stream.
And if you have an Amazon prime subscription,
you can subscribe to twitch prime for free.
It costs you nothing
but it counts as a paid subscription for us.
All of that at twitch.tv/fee with pacman.
I hope you'll check it out.